- Welcome back, y'all.
(audience clapping)
We are celebrating Christmas
with Taraji P. Henson.
Give it up!
(audience cheering)
You can see her in "The Color Purple"
starting Christmas Day in theaters.
Speaking of Christmas Day,
Taraji and I both love it.
So some might say a little
too much, but who cares?
- [Taraji] Who cares?
- We don't care what you think.
- No.
(audience laughing)
- We love Christmas and
you will not take it.
(audience laughs)
So we thought Taraji would
be the perfect person
to play our annual Christmas game.
Here's this year's round of
the Christmostest Hostess.
♪ The Christmostest Hostess ♪
(audience clapping)
It's really hard to say,
if I'm being honest.
Here to host is a good friend of the show.
You can see him on "That
Clip Show: Holiday Edition"
tonight on NBC.
Everybody give it up for
our friend Matt Iseman!
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
(inaudible dialogue)
- Good to see you again.
- Good to see you!
- Is this your first time
being on our New York set?
- First time in New York.
- Yes. Well, thank you.
- I love being here.
What better Christmas spirit gift than
to be here with Kelly and Taraji.
- Oh. Absolutely.
I agree. I agree.
- Yes.
- So tell us about the game. We are ready.
- All right, so this is how
Christmostest hostess works.
- Okay.
- I'm gonna ask you a series
of questions about Christmas,
- Okay.
- Christmas parties, and Christmas decor.
If you get the question
right, you get a point,
but if you get it wrong,
you have to take a shot of
that delicious but filling
eggnog in front of you.
- [Taraji] Okay.
- Okay.
- [Matt] Now steals are allowed.
- Yes.
- [Taraji] Oh.
- But if you get it wrong in a steal,
you still do a shot.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- The winner will get a gift
for her side of the audience.
(audience cheers)
They always love that part
and will have her name inscribed
on the Christmostest Hostess
ornament that will live on
at the Kelly Clarkson Show
for many Christmases to come.
(audience cheers)
- Alright
- Ladies.
- Alright.
- The stakes have never been higher.
Buzz in when you think
you know the answer.
- Okay.
- [Matt] Are you ready
for Christmostest Hostess?
(audience cheers)
- [Taraji] Okay.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Here we go.
- First question.
- Okay.
- What? Kissy kissy Christmas decoration
(buzzer rings)
- Mistletoe!
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
(bell dings)
Oh my God.
(audience cheers)
- We're gonna win, baby! We're gonna win!
(Taraji laughs)
- That was very fast.
- [Taraji] Kissy. Kissy.
- I need more caffeine.
- I'm not a betting man.
- I didn't know if he was
going song or mistletoe.
I didn't know.
- I just took a chance.
Not gonna wait for it.
- [Kelly] Okay.
I'm gonna lose.
- Visions of losing dance in her head.
- Yup. Yup.
(Taraji laughs)
- Question two.
What decorative shell
splitter is also the name
(buzzer rings)
- Elf.
Where's my elf? Hiding elf.
(buzzer sound)
- That is incorrect.
- Elfie.
(audience laughs)
- Taraji, take a shot.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] You don't have
to take the whole thing.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
- [Taraji] I'm gonna get some more wrong.
- Alright, Kelly, you have a
chance to steal down one point.
What decorative shell
splitter is also the name
of a Christmas ballet.
(buzzer rings)
- Nutcracker!
- Nutcracker! No. No. I get it! I get it!
Nutcracker. I get it.
- Taraji, you already got this one wrong.
- Oh.
- This is for Kelly.
Kelly. Do you know the answer?
- Nutcracker.
- Yes.
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- Oh my God.
- Question three. What are two other names
for Santa Claus?
- Oh!
(buzzer rings)
- [Matt] Kelly.
- Saint Nick.
- [Matt] Yes.
- And
Kris Kringle.
(bell dings)
- Yes!
(audience cheers)
- That is correct!
(audience continues cheering)
- For those keeping score at home.
Taraji did not get the question wrong,
but she still did a shot.
(audience laughs)
- Oh!
- It's two to one, and
Taraji has three shots
of eggnog here, everybody.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] She just likes eggnog.
- [Matt] Here we go.
Question number four.
- [Kelly] My stomach
(sleigh bells ringing)
would be a mess.
- I believe I heard the jingle bells,
which means
- We're finished?
- there is one question left.
- And, and this one wins everything.
- Well, Taraji.
- What?
- This could be worth six points.
(crowd cheers)
Six points at stake.
The title of Christmostest
Hostess on the line.
Last question.
- Okay.
- On the third day of Christmas,
what did my two love-
(buzzer rings)
Kelly.
- [Taraji] Ah. It won't even-
(Kelly hums)
- Three golden hens? No.
- [Matt] Incorrect!
(buzzer sound)
- No, no, no.
- Taraji!
You must get this correct.
To win the Christmostest Hostess title.
(Kelly mumbles song)
- Oh. It's-
- [Taraji] Nah!
(audience giggling)
(Matt imitates Italian accent)
- We need an answer
at this momente.
- What is it?
- French hens.
- French hens!
(bell dings)
- Three French hens!
(crowd cheers)
Taraji. You are the champion!
- [Kelly] I knew it was a bird.
- Kelly.
- I knew it was a bird.
- Because I could...
- Are you gonna take one?
- I'll take one with you.
- [Taraji] I'll take one with you.
- Salud!
(audience continues cheering)
- So good.
- You know how I know it's real.
I mean because it tastes
amazing. That is so good.
- It's so good.
- I hope it doesn't hit me later. Okay.
(Taraji laughs)
- It is so good though.
Of course, we are all winners around here.
Iconic Australian footwear
brand Frankie4 is changing
the lives of everyday women,
especially those that are
on their feet all day long.
Their game changing
sneakers, flats, heels,
and boots have podiatrist design support,
which has earned them over
100,000 five-star reviews
and a global following.
And you're all going home with
a $300 Frankie4 gift card!
(audience cheers)
Thank you for hosting.
Welcome to our New York show.
- Oh. Thank you. You're the best.
- Everybody, be sure
to watch it all tonight
"That Clip Show: Holiday Edition" on NBC,
and Taraji's movie "The Color Purple".
Go see it in theaters
starting Christmas Day.
We'll be right back with Grammy
winning artist Killer Mike.